or in Washington DC is 50 minutes while
Dick Cheney has been in the political
arena for years there has been a
noticeable lack of information available
about his background luckily mr. Nichols
has stepped to the plate providing a
well researched and humorous biography
shedding light on one of the most
influential men in the current Bush
administration while John Nichols
previous work includes it's the media
stupid art media not theirs and Jews for
P cannon currently mr. Nichols runs the
editorial page of Madison's Capital
Times newspaper and is a correspondent
for the Nation magazine I have a quote
here that I think you guys will enjoy of
all the dragonslayers now afoot in the
American desert John Nichols Ward is the
sharpest from gore Vidal please help me
welcome John Nichols I will keep I will
keep my sword sheathed through most of
the evening and I am honored to be on
the politics in prose stage we're only a
week ago Jon Stewart was president were
any of you there at Jon Stewart's
reading I see some folks who were and
and I promise I will not call anyone on
CNN a dick tonight well I think I think
the case has been well established it's
pretty well pretty well finished but I
do you know I was very pleased that he
did use the book's title in that moment
we're going to talk about Dick Cheney
for a little bit tonight I will talk for
about 20 minutes and then we'll take
some questions and I am I am just I want
to make sure everybody gets a chance to
see the debates yeah and I just say if
you note to young authors if you want to
write a book about somebody in
administration take the vice president
and hope for a debate pattern like we
had this year because after that first
debate I felt I didn't really need to
make much of a case about who was in
charge of the country a George Bush came
on and
yeah y'all but said you know Jesus
president is really hard and it didn't
say it once probably dozen times and
then you know he kind of struggled
through through debate after debate he
finally got down to the one thing he was
very very good at which was explaining
how to get a flu shot and then a good
description of how to pray which I
thought he did rather well but but when
you got down to the nuts and bolts of
running this administration you really
needed to go to that second debate and
watch Dick Cheney because Dick Cheney
sat there you know cool calm I know if
people often asked why does he talk into
his shirt like that the answer is this
is a guy who has never had to enunciate
and in his life you know he's used to
having hundreds of terrified minions
leaped to their feet and run out and do
whatever he tells them to do so I didn't
have to yell very loud but in that
debate he did make the basic effort to
communicate and it is true that much of
the communication was lies but at least
he went for it and and I want to focus
on that one wonderful statement that
that our vice president made as regards
his opponent in which he said you know I
will paraphrase here but essentially you
know I go up to Capitol Hill every
Tuesday to preside over the Senate and I
and this is the first time that I've
ever met you John Edwards well of course
that was a lie but but it was actually a
wonderful lie it was one of the one of
those multi-tiered lies that you don't
hear so often in our politics and and
say I just wanted to take it apart for a
little bit as all of you I'm sure know
John Edwards and Dick Cheney had met not
once but many times in fact they had sat
in Tim Russert's greenroom they had been
to prayer breakfasts forever they have
tapes of Dick Cheney talking about John
Edwards but the best part of it was that
that wasn't the only lie the other lie
is I go up and I preside over the Senate
every Tuesday well if you go to the
Senate's website and you look at who was
the presiding officer and all the
Tuesday's of this administration you'll
find I believe that there were only two
times the Dick Cheney actually presided
over the side so here he was saying oh
boy John Edwards you don't show up
you're irresponsible well the guy who's
the boss of the Senate one there
except for two times and then the final
part of the lie my favorite part is why
Dick Cheney does go up to Capitol Hill
on Tuesdays it isn't to meet with the
whole Senate it's not to say you know
why my noble loyal opposition let us
discuss you know politics and prose no
he goes up he goes up there to meet in
private session with the Republican
caucus to give them their marching
orders for the week so no he wouldn't
have met John Edwards unless John
Edwards switched parties in fact the
only time he actually interacts with
members of the opposite party on Capitol
Hill is of course to give friendly
greetings to Patrick Leahy but I the
fictions of Dick Cheney's service as our
so-called Vice President are nothing
compared to the actual broader fiction
the one that that's so few of us talk
about and that is the structure of this
administration and I always remind
people that if you just step back from
the current process and take a look at
if you would if you had landed here the
proverbial Martian and took a look at
this administration you would have no
question who was in charge it's not a
very complicated scenario in July of
2000 Dick Cheney selected himself to be
the vice president
Cheil candidate on the Republican ticket
then after the Florida debacle of 2000
but before the Supreme Court had
actually chosen the next president
Dick Cheney flew into suburban Virginia
and set up the transition office Bush
was down there on the ranch and I do
believe that George Bush actually
uttered the most honest statement of his
political career when during the Florida
recount process a reporter asked him
well you know you must be very tense and
he said no not really you know if I if
if it doesn't work I'll I'll just come
back down here to Texas and have a good
life and I think Bush totally meant that
but you never heard any such line from
Dick Cheney he was up in Washington area
you know time bringing they said there
was one description dana Milbank from
The Washington Post wrote a wonderful
description of Cheney in the office I
believe it was knowing where he was
sitting at a desk and he had a pile of
cell phones in front of him several
landlines computers all around
I mean because he was okay he was like
in constant motion and this was after he
had had one of his frequent heart
attacks and yet no problem at all no
slowdown because this was a man who was
taking charge
choosing cabinet members people in the
sub cabinet with folks who he had worked
with over 30 some years in politics
making this administration so he picks
himself to be vice president then he
does the transition ten days into the
administration what does he do in the
most energy obsessed administration in
the history of this country
Dick Cheney becomes the head of the
energy task force and of course meets in
secret but you know runs you know that
what is a key initiative of this
administration and now we find out also
that you know goodness me what a quirky
unexplainable thing they had maps of
Iraq's oil fields that they were
reviewing for the energy task force who
would have thought and so once they got
done doing the energy task for cities up
on Capitol Hill the lead lobbyist for
the bush economic agenda the tax plans
all the the trade initiatives other
deals that they're working on always
went bush you know down on vacation you
know on vacation more than any president
in American history campaigning more
than any president in American history
works out up to two hours a day looking
grabbed you seen Bush recently guys in
fabulous shape now Cheney right eating
at the desk
you know like always on the run not
getting to the gym as much I mean let's
let's be clear who's got the the free
time in this administration and then you
get down to the heart of the matter you
know which is why don't we know this why
don't we why don Americans talking about
this in a much more detailed and
invigorated an engaged way well far be
it for me to criticize the media I I
think Jon Stewart did that well last
week but but let me suggest you that we
have a media in this country that is you
know I'm telling you if they were by the
parade route they would be the ones turn
into the little kid and saying no the
king the Emperor he is clothed honestly
look they you just can't see his lovely
garments and and it comes home in two
recent incidents
during on the campaign trail Dick Cheney
is out campaigning as many of you may be
aware now he campaigns in much the
manner of Brezhnev back in the old
Soviet Union it's a it's a flight out to
a very loyal sort of you know
well-organized state in which he meets
with the members of the Party Central
Committee in a quiet comfortable setting
and has the you know loyal pass and
Pravda traveling along to take their
notes no tough questions the New York
Times by the way not allowed on the
campaign plane they had wonderful I hope
you saw it the wonderful story about the
New York Times writer who tried to keep
up with Cheney with planes trains and
automobiles because Cheney would let him
on the plane so very friendly press very
friendly audiences traveling around the
country and making you know that the
reasoned thoughtful pronouncements of a
man of state you know for instance you
know I don't trust John Kerry to stand
up for our national security I don't
think he's committed to keeping America
safe it's incredible line right you know
it's like but of course you know yes
well the vice president of it's been
sitting around you know kind of going
through some paperwork analyzing things
and come to the conclusion that Kerry
just wasn't trustworthy really that you
couldn't count on this guy to defend the
United States and I thought you know
this would have been it for somewhat
more engaged media it might have been an
interesting point at which to review the
track records of the two people in play
you know I said John Kerry volunteers to
go to Vietnam then he goes gets over
there he says no you know I'm not in
enough combat on this ship off the shore
I want to get on a swift boat and go
straight into the enemy fire right so
that's John Kerry okay you know just now
he's apparently vice president views not
committed enough to defend the country
but then here you got our vice president
who I mean you know I assume you're any
enterprising reporter would ask as we do
in the book um you know what did Dick
Cheney do during the Vietnam War and let
me tell you something there's nobody was
more committed to the anti-draft
movement than Dick Cheney not actually
for other people but for himself Dick
Cheney had five deferments during the
Vietnam War which is a pretty pretty
good track record there
three of them were student deferments
you know he wasn't the first guy to get
as a student deferment not the best
student he did get kicked out of Yale
and then he didn't finish his graduate
work at the University of Wisconsin but
still you know kind of keep it in school
there and getting those deferments but
things got a little some of you who may
have somewhat of white hair may recall
that Vietnam was not the most convenient
war didn't work out perfectly kind of
kept needing more troops and as they
needed more troops they got a little
tighter on the student deferments and so
the word came down you know it might be
a little more convenient if you were
married you know student and married
probably less likely to get sent over
and what a wonderful coincidence within
months after the announcement that being
married would help you to get a stronger
deferment dick and Lynne Cheney
succumbed to the passions of their
ten-year long relationship and decided
to marry now war can do that to people
but the the final deferment that Dick
Cheney got was the most remarkable it
was a child the firm it's a deferment
for a married individual who has a child
certainly very legitimate you don't want
to be sending fathers off to die in wars
and it's interesting because that the
announcement that that parents were not
likely to be drafted that that was gonna
be one of your strongest affirmance came
on a particular day you know but mid-60s
there and nine months and two days later
Lynne Cheney delivered their first child
coincidence you say well maybe not the
biggest coincidence because two and a
half months after Lynne Cheney got
pregnant which she was in her first
trimester
Dick Cheney trooped down to the draft
board and requested the child deferment
so while we we now know two things
they're important about Dick Cheney he
favors pre-emptive war and he also
favors pre-emptive draft evasion
that story was missing in this long
discussion about John Kerry's Vietnam
record
why because Dick Cheney doesn't like to
be covered by the media and he isn't
covered very often he isn't even covered
when he makes pronouncements about the
physical danger that America will be in
if John Kerry is elected this is a big
you know he said you know that John Cruz
I'm really kind of scared again
thoughtful reason analysis comes to the
conclusion if John Kerry is elected I
think you know we were gonna really face
the risk of attack once again if the
reporters are out there taking their
notes who the vice presidents come to
the conclusion if John Kerry is elected
we're going to be attacked
back this week he was out talking about
nuclear bombs if the other guys win is
getting it was getting pretty serious
and you know the problem with that is
you would hope that some journalists and
some do and I give great credit to some
wonderful journalists affect so many of
them inform this book but you think that
a lot of our broadcast media might want
to take a little look at Dick Cheney's
judgment I mean is this the kind of guy
who could really reason through these
issues and come to the conclusion that
if the other guys win were really
endangered and I always like to remind
folks of the pinnacle of Dick Cheney's
judgment which came in the 1980s the
late 1980s when the Congress of the
United States was asked to vote on a
resolution urging the Reagan
administration to do everything in its
power to force South Africa to release
Nelson Mandela from the apartheid
prisons of that country and you know
this was in the late 1980s at a time
when jack kemp was calling Nelson
Mandela a freedom fighter when Newt
Gingrich was referring to him as a hero
and only a handful of mostly southern
members of Congress voted against the
resolution calling for Mandela's release
they were joined by Dick Cheney not once
but on every single resolution calling
for the United States to work against
apartheid or to work for the release of
Nelson Mandela Dick Cheney voted no why
did he vote no because he said in his
reasoned judgment that this almost 70
year old man who had been in prison for
27 years 28 29 30 was know as terrorists
and that the
see was a terrorist organization and you
had to you know it can't go slack on it
now man this is a very serious fight and
that was not the only example of bizarre
misjudgment by Dick Cheney when he was
Secretary of Defense he didn't like the
fact that the Schwarzkopf Schwarzkopf
was a wimp and Cheney's view Schwarzkopf
didn't want to go into Baghdad so
Cheney's spent millions of dollars
setting up a secret team within his
office to develop operation scorpion the
plan to invade Baghdad it was a detailed
plan it was actually done entirely by
civilians there were no military people
involved and one of the primary offices
bookends one of the thing one of the
prime movers on the plan was a guy who
said he got a lot of his ideas from
Lawrence of Arabia and so they come in
with this big plan and roll it out
Schwarzkopf is there right before the
war starts and you know all the generals
are around for getting their first look
at Dick Cheney's plan to invade Baghdad
and Schwarzkopf and some of the others
say well you know it's really
interesting plan there dick but you see
problem here is you'd get the entire you
know whole sections of the US military
out in the Iraqi desert without water
because there's no supply lines in this
plan I see it that that's not a good
idea wouldn't work and so they started
all the generals start explaining that
it would be a total disaster be one of
the worst military moves ever and so
slowly that the plan is rolled up and
put away and dick and Schwarzkopf writes
in one of in his autobiography that
working with Dick Cheney reminded me of
the danger that occurs when the
civilians try to out general the
generals and again and again through his
career Dick Cheney's judgment has been
exceptionally questionable most recently
as regards the war in Iraq and in this
book which which by the way I was
reading on the way out you know I was on
the plane and I gotta tell you fine fine
text you made
I don't know how the elections gonna
turn out but I think it still make a
good Christmas present but anyway so I'm
reading through that I'm reading through
the book here and I can't tell you how
much I enjoy doing so but I close the
book off with an analysis of the war and
it's spent a lot of time talking about
how Dick Cheney
was of course the prime point man for
this work not just the prime point man
in once the administration came to power
I invite you to look back at the debates
of 2000 when George Bush appeared in the
debates and he said you know I'm going
for this nation building stuff I don't
think we should be the policemen of the
world running around invading places you
know I we and Bush actually said
wonderful say you said said you know I
really don't think we can go to other
countries to tell them how to do things
just because we do them that way all
these statements they say well they're
do the infinites nicest thing I heard
the guy say in all the debates Cheney on
the other hand the vice presidential
debate talk for the better part of ten
minutes about the need to do something
about Iraq and to use deadly force
remarkable dichotomy see ask yourself
which guy got elected president the one
who didn't want to do nation-building
didn't want to be the policeman of the
world or the guy who said we might have
to use some deadly force in Iraq Cheney
appeared just before the start of the
war on Meet the Press which is of course
our our official program for making
public pronouncements and I close the
book with a little section as regards
that appearance that Meet the Press
again and again during the hour-long
interview Cheney said of the Iraqi
people they will welcome us as
liberators
this was Cheney at the peak of his power
reviewing it as he had only briefly on
September 11 and during the days that
followed that he was fully in charge he
had the plan and he had the power to
implement it and for every sincere
concern that might be expressed he had a
false promise at the ready as the
interview progressed Cheney made fewer
mentions of President Bush he kept
saying we with the our winding down
there were no longer any mentions of
Bush and that we was sounding more and
more royal finally Russert asked whether
fiscal sense might argue for suspending
a proposed tax cut for the rich in or
to pay for the war we don't believe
that's the right course of action Tim
this is one of those times when as
important as the war on terror is as
important as the problem of Iraq is
we've also got a lot of other balls in
the air Cheney said and an American
president these days doesn't have the
choice of focusing on only one thing
Dick Cheney was by now the machiavelli
of his age having beaten his only
serious rival the Pretender Rumsfeld for
a place at the elbow of a boy king who
would ever defer to his Regent yet
Cheney had never bothered to develop the
knowledge or the ability to honestly
assess information that would have
allowed him to rule wisely the fatal
flaw in Cheney schemes had turned out to
be Cheney 34 years after he had arrived
in Washington is barely an intern he had
made himself the most powerful man in
the city and the world beyond he had the
authority to decide between peace and
war and he had chosen war not because it
was necessary not because but because it
satisfied his needs politically
economically and emotionally now people
would die
soldiers contractors civilians the
violence would over times swell those
who were supposed to greet Americans as
liberators would take up arms and the
promise of greater security from
terrorism which Cheney had made with
such assurance would come to be seen as
the absurd boast of a man so desperate
to begin a war that he never stopped to
consider its consequences there would
need to be an accounting and in the
spring of 2004 it was demanded having
heard Richard Clark's charge that the
administration have been more obsessed
with regime change in Iraq than with
taking the necessary steps to combat
terrorism which was again surfacing in
the form of bombings that had left more
than 200 Spaniards dead the members of
the National Commission on terrorist
attacks on the United States had
prevailed upon the president to meet
with them in secret but the president
would not appear on his own he would
come with Dick Cheney at his side it was
a necessary pairing White House aides
acknowledged and the Commission accepted
that George W Bush could not provide
answers to the most basic questions
about the rationale for the war on Iraq
let alone how it
related to the war on terrorism Iraq was
not his project he was to be sure
responsible as the war had been waged in
his name but how could he explain that
which he had not conceived and had never
fully understood for that the Commission
would need to hear from Dick Cheney of
all the powers afforded to the man who
occupies the Oval Office none is more
awesome than the authority to lead the
most powerful nation in the world to war
yet George W Bush who had campaigned for
president as a reluctant warrior who did
not want to be the world's policeman had
only placed a seal of approval on
another man's plan to launch a
preemptive war against a distant land
this was not Bush's war this was
Cheney's war and because of that this
was not george w bush's presidency it
was Dick Cheney's when school children
go to the backs of their American
history books they encounter charts that
lists the Presidents and vice presidents
of the United States but the facts of
America's decision to go to war with
Iraq in the spring of 2003 made a lie of
those charts and history itself is
threatened so let it be recorded here
that in the first years of the 21st
century at a time when American faith in
itself had been shaken the White House
became a place of dark and dangerous
intrigues the Oval Office was occupied
by a weak and disengaged president in
name only but the authority of the
presidency up to and including the power
to plan and wage war was gripped by an
unrelenting ly ambitious yet tragically
ill-prepared man named Richard Bruce
Cheney dick the man who is president
thank you I entertained your questions
or I'll stand here uncomfortably let me
turn to this woman first and then I I
believe we're asked to use the
microphone if we can because we have
there our friends here filming
do you anticipate no matter which of the
candidates wins the election that there
may be any investigations after after
the election that might lead to any
criminal charges against against Cheney
and others in the administration it's a
wonderful question and and you know one
thing to be aware of is there are
already many investigations in Clay Dick
Cheney has been investigated by the SEC
in Halliburton as well there's been all
sorts of other other investigations into
aspects of his service Henry Waxman who
is to my mind one of the handful of
members of Congress who actually takes
seriously the duty that the founders in
this country laid upon members of
Congress which is to keep an eye on the
executive has if you go to his website
and I recommend it it's just packed with
information that would form the basis
for a terrific investigation but I have
to tell you in the ugly partisan period
in which we live it is unlikely that
there will be any serious investigations
of this administration unless we have a
change in the control of the United
States Senate it is really as simple as
that
and and that's a tragedy because I will
tell you I mean you can criticize
Republicans Democrats I think there are
some wonderful Republicans in Congress I
have high regard for lincoln Chafee for
Richard Lugar even for people I might
disagree with on some issues like Hagel
and McCain there are Republicans there
who are willing to do an investigation
unfortunately they are not in the
positions of power to advance it and
this Senate is so controlled I don't see
that happening I will tell you why it is
such a tragedy though remember that the
Vietnam War was investigated by the
Senate I mean that that Senate tore that
war open particularly Fulbright's
Foreign Relations Committee and it was
Democrats who were in the lead of
investigating the wrongs of a Democratic
president the crime the tragedy in this
country today is that Republicans have
at least up to this point been unwilling
to hold their own president and vice
president accountable for acts that any
good American citizen knows deserve
investigation I close off with one final
point on this too it hope folks have
been noticing the endorsement pattern of
newspapers around the country many of
the most conservative newspapers in the
United States have that endorsed George
Bush in 2000 have refused to endorse him
for re-election this time out in the
countryside there are many conservatives
who see the flaws in this administration
this is not a liberal or conservative
thing this is not a Republican or
Democrat thing this is an administration
that has gone far far astray both of its
duties and also of the laws and
traditions of this country and
Republicans should be in the forefront
of investigating it could you say a
little bit about Cheney's relationship
with the professional military
particularly the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs and the Joint Chiefs and also
with the professionals in central
intelligence agency sure they don't like
him know a little more detail I
appreciate that
all right now some of the best sources
for this book are our military folks and
some of the most wonderful quotes in it
you know Dick Cheney served as Secretary
of Defense and when he served as
Secretary of Defense he had he when his
first acts was to tell Colin Powell you
stay in your place and in fact it was
very blunt message from Cheney that he
was going to be in charge of the
department offense and Nepal over at
Joint Chiefs you know that was you know
you just keep out of my way
and it was a very it was a tense
relationship it remains a tense
relationship to this day you know that
you read Robert Wood roots book which I
you know you have to but if you read
Robert Boyd roots book you will see in
it that there are there's a lot of
detail about the terrible relations
between Cheney and Powell to this day
and that's rooted back to the the late
1980s early 1990s at one important thing
to understand Cheney as Secretary of
Defense use that position in some
absolutely
the troubling ways that trouble the
generals they were very very bothered by
what was going on with his secret
planning for extending the war in Iraq
but also that satisfied an awfully lot
of people in the business community
because Dick Cheney was in the forefront
of efforts to privatize the military in
the latter days of his services
secretary defense he put out bids for
proposals for analysis on how to
privatize a lot of military activity
things that were done by soldiers and he
hired a fascinating who take a guess
what company hired to do this crazy but
it Brown and Root a subsidiary of
Halliburton right brown road yeah and
they and you know amazingly enough they
came back with a report that said it's a
really good idea to privatize a lot of
the military and the first contracts
were let to Brown and Root a subsidiary
of Halliburton and we now if you look at
Iraq right now and you want to
understand a lot of the crisis in Iraq
it is that all sorts of things that used
to be done by soldiers who were armed
and who were trained to do serious work
has now been taken over by contractors
who are paid a lot of money to do really
awful things and you know war costs more
it is less efficient it's a bigger mess
because of privatization of the military
I'm not the one saying this there are
generals and Colonels and lieutenant
Colonel's saying this very bluntly I've
got a lot of them quoted in the book and
that privatization process roots back to
Cheney so there's an awful lot of people
in the military who have real objections
to how this guy has related them to them
for a long time finally just on the CIA
reference I the folks over the CIA
actually complained about Cheney they
complain to the House Intelligence
Committee they said look Cheney keeps
coming over here requesting different
briefing officers because he can't get
one of them to tell him that there are
weapons of mass destruction and it were
in Iraq okay to connection he wants
certain things we told him and we
doesn't hear it he demands another
briefing officer and I've got in the
book the letter that was sent to Cheney
by number of members of the House
Intelligence Committee telling him to
back off the CIA I'm amazed it still
amazes me that that wasn't a front-page
story broadly covered all over this
country I wish I could tell you this
great investigative report I'm not it's
easy to find this stuff it's all there
the problem is
the Cheney has been so little covered
that most people don't know that
members of the Congress demanded that he
back off in these unreasonable demands
on the CIA to make up information about
Iraq sir thank you very much for
wonderful talk if the unthinkable
happens and Cheney and Bush re-elected
what ambitions do you think Cheney will
have for the next four years what what
ambitions what ambitions not very good
people often ask me you know it's like
after they read the book they become
convinced that Cheney really is gonna
run for president in 2008 I don't think
it's gonna happen i I think Dick Cheney
throughout his entire career has been
exceptionally satisfied to play
precisely the role that he is playing he
you know when he was in the Ford
administration they called him backseat
because he always got in the backseat
with the powerful guy and sat next to
him if it was Ford he was right there
next to him and and I think that's
always what he's like to be he's like to
be the guy next to the powerful figure
making things happen
a Cheney did briefly run for president
in 1993 1994 and to the immense credit
of the Republican Party they took a
serious look at him and said we're not
running you we want somebody exciting
like Bob Dole but but the fact is you
know Cheney knows he's not running for
president he pulls way below way below
George Bush and I think he's very
satisfied with the role that he's in now
his ambition for a second term though is
very blunt I and I know people I can't
believe this debate we got going on
whether the Republicans are in favor of
privatizing Social Security of course
they are it's in their platform you know
they like take oh that's unfair to
charge us with it no it's in their
platform this is their program give Dick
Cheney and George Bush another term and
they will spend immense amounts of money
on Iraq and other foreign ambitions they
will lower taxes for the rich and they
will have no money left to run anything
else in the government and so then they
will say you know hey we got this crazy
idea for how to balance the books let's
privatize Social Security and that will
become an immense pressure in the second
term I mean this is again it is only in
some sort of fantastical Alice in
Wonderland moment that anyone would
debate whether that is part of the
agenda of course it is because we're
broke and
they have been dipping into the Social
Security funds forever not them the
Republic Democrats do so I mean the
pressure there in the second term is
gonna be pretty clear sir
connection with the last question during
the vice presidential debate mr. senator
Edwards said that it's true that Kerry
voted against some weapons systems but
those were the same ones that Secretary
of Defense the Secretary of Defense
Cheney sought to kill one of the reasons
the generals didn't like him um actually
no that wasn't that wasn't the core
reason the reason that the generals had
a real objection with Dick Cheney was
that he didn't really seem to work very
well with generals remember he wasn't a
man and he's not a military man he had
no background in the military he had as
we noted before been very meticulous
about avoiding contact with other
soldiers during the Vietnam War and and
their problem with him was that he
seemed to be more passionate about sort
of the business aspect of running the
military then the military aspect of it
and so you had the privatization stuff
you also had you know I gotta tell you I
spent I grew up in a military family
I've spent my father served in the in
the Air Force for decades and and I
spent a lot of time around military
folks they're not happy warriors most
people the military are very sensible
about you know when particularly career
military about when we ought to go to
war and what we ought to do and an awful
lot of military folks are exceptionally
uncomfortable with the project for a new
American Century and all of these sort
of adventure plans for how you know
we're gonna insert ourselves around the
world and Cheney when he was secretary
defence was so engaged with this way of
thinking that I think he really did put
off a lot of military folks in and I
think it was very much to their credit
again I think if the generals were in
charge we would not be fighting in Iraq
today sir
how do you explain that Cheney and the
administration has gotten such a free
shot at not having to explain why they
were unprepared for 9/11 and why they
had to give secret and joint testimony
to the 9/11 Commission yeah no come on
it's only Lewis Carroll must be raised
from the dead
to explain you know how the media the
United States said Oh Chinese gonna
appear with Bush that's cool and I mean
what this is an absurdity I mean yeah
and do you know that Gerald Ford and yet
Gerald Ford was not exactly viewed as
the rocket scientist president of all
time but Gerald Ford went to the
Congress of the United States to explain
the Nixon pardon he sat there on his own
in front of a bunch of angry people at a
time when it was exceptionally unpopular
and he took the heat in public with the
television cameras on this guy Bush
won't even do it in private and he
brings his vice president with him so I
think it's a it's an exceptionally
problematic situation and the bigger
problem to me is again the the failure
to look seriously at how this
administration is structured I think
that's an American problem not a not
just a media problem or not just a bush
administration problem we are far less
comfortable in this country with looking
at the allocation of power and realizing
that it that it's not always in the
hands of the person we elected it makes
us very uncomfortable because we're
taught and I was in my little school in
Union Grove Wisconsin we're taught that
this is a democracy we choose our
leaders and so it's discomforting to us
to see that the power may rest elsewhere
and in different places and yet it does
and so as a people we have a
responsibility to be much more
aggressive in looking at you know who
holds what power who's doing what and I
will tell you something this book is out
in Europe and in Canada and other places
when I do interviews on with European
interviews I was an Austrian radio the
other day and I've done CBC in Canada a
whole bunch and you know add you foreign
folks they get it completely
there's used to a cabinet form of
government they say yes of course we
understand sometimes you'll have a weak
but attractive Prime Minister but then a
really powerful Chancellor of the
Exchequer behind him or there's someone
out this is how it works is they said
Americans we still live in the fantasy
that our presidents are these superhuman
figures who are in charge of everything
that goes on we ourselves need to break
that fantasy we need to recognize that
that just is not the reality and then we
need to demand a media that reports to
us in detail on reality rather than on
you know this lingering
annecy of the strongman president who
can do everything my friend I thank you
very much for your talk in your book I
picked it up about three four days ago
and was musing over this book because
I've been saying for probably three
years that I wanted to create a bumper
sticker
you've heard of here first if you ever
see it that says Bush are heartbeat away
from the presidency
and I feel vindicated now you know
you're not supposed to upstage the
author at the reading but in any case be
that as it may one thing that you didn't
touch on here and I hadn't had a chance
to read in the book yet is they're not
those people stayed up all night reading
all the way through no because I have
other really good books that I'm just
glad I didn't write about Bush so yeah
cause there's like 100 um but like just
interrupts yeah there's one woman a
friend of mine who I gave the book to
this friend of mine and her daughter
picked it up she's not real political
but she just started reading it and she
said after like three nights she was
having these nightmares about Cheney
chasing her and I think that is the
ultimate compliment you know anyways
well no I mean I didn't read it because
I know I mention that before I go to bed
I don't read comedies or tragedies and
that's what that is
you know so there are many lines of what
what's going on there's the
privatization of the military which I
had been speaking about with friends of
mine for some time as I had observed
developing if you will there is a
privatization of the government the
usurpation of the governor McCrory very
wearisome is something which I'm
wondering what role Cheney has in it and
that is the the wholesale obliteration
of parts of the Constitution and you
know III guess I fear that the only
amendment the Constitution in the next
three or four years that'll be paid any
attention to is the one they're trying
to push through to have no marriage
between men and I'm wondering now if
that's because they want to make sure
that that can't be an exclusion for
males if there's a draft
but anyway
whoa things go bad enough who may have
gays the military yet my friend I will
direct you to there's I actually have a
section on this and I it deals with mr.
Cheney's congressional service it's
titled contempt for Congress and my
friend and hero John Dean the the
Watergate not here oh well it was here
Oh Watergate but and former Nixon
administration counsel is informed my
knowledge of how the White House works
so much and one of the things that and
he's written a lot about this as well
and and one of the things that Dean
points out and that I really spent a lot
of time exploring is Cheney's absolute
contempt for the separation of powers
you know one of the things is we think
of the Constitution as only the ten
amendments at the end you know or the
well the initial amendments and then all
the ones we've added over the years but
but the fact is the Constitution is
actually a very good structure for how a
government ought to work in many ways
you know you didn't that Madison and
Jefferson didn't want one individual to
have too much power
Madison warned if you read back in
Madison's writings the man warned with a
passion about how war was the the tool
of executive aggrandizement he didn't
like Wars because he said if you have
them presidents will cease too much
power into their office they will use
fear to become more dominant and so the
founders of this kind of hold it that's
the founders were very conscious of this
stuff and the Constitution is a
wonderful document in that regard and
Dick Cheney just despises all of those
aspects of the Constitution that
suggests that you might want to consult
with Congress now he was the one back in
1990 who advised his the former
President Bush not to go to Congress for
permission to go into Kuwait and then if
they had to go into Iraq he didn't want
to do that he said don't and it's a guy
who had just come out of Congress he was
also the guy who led the defense of the
Reagan administration during the
iran-contra investigations and if you go
back and read the things he wrote during
iran-contra they will blow your mind I
mean because here all Republicans Warren
Rudman all these guys are saying you
know look we have you know we've got to
clean this mess up you can't be like
trading drugs
you know weapons and it's not good you
know it I mean and and yet Dick Cheney
the if you read the Minority Report that
he put on in on iran-contra it is full
of stuff like saying you know we just
can't be stomping on the president's
power here you know we got a we got a
step back and he was terrified by the
idea of Congress actually asserting its
constitutionally defined role so I don't
want to be too arcane here but I do want
to suggest that if you really want to
explore the most dangerous aspect of
this administration it is not the
Patriot Act although I think that's
incredibly dangerous and I'm proud to
come from Wisconsin where Russ Feingold
was the only senator to vote against the
Patriot Act but I want to tell you
something the most dangerous part of
this administration is the fuzzing of
all those lines and endi really
elimination of the structures that give
Congress the power to oversee the White
House and we know somebody else asked
about winners of the investigations
going to come this administration has
done more than any Administration in
history in fact John Dean says much more
than Nixon to weaken the ability of
Congress to make sure that a president
does not go out of control and I would
suggest to you that this war in Iraq
alone is the evidence that this
administration has gone out of control
sir yes probably more than any time in
my life there's less to trust it seems
like and from the media as well as from
the politicians but I wonder if you have
any insights on this issue that came up
recently about the draft what do you
think that Cheney and his crowd will do
about that right yeah well he's overage
now and the second thing are there any
secret Wars out there that we haven't
heard about yet oh yeah the secret Wars
all the time brother I mean we've got
troops spread around this ya keep to
take the last part of your question
first
we've got troops out you know we keep
saying we don't have enough troops for
Iraq there's a reason we don't have
enough troops for RAC we've got a heck
of a lot of troops spread all over this
planet in you know every seems like just
about every place that's got stand on
the end of its name has some US troops
sitting there and I wonder you know why
would that be could it possibly be
because there's a whole bunch of oil in
all those former Soviet states but no
so Secret Wars are in the offering all
over the place I don't think it's North
Korea or Iran I think it's I if I was
remember the Assad family and in Syria
I'd be a little scared because there
seems to be a lot of they keep making a
lot of noise there but I also I think
the former Soviet states all those
stands with a lot of oil and a lot of
Muslims it looked like the kind of
places that this administration would be
very interested in so that's where I
focus a lot of my attention the first
part about the draft the draft is a
weird issue it's a weird issue that it's
sort of arisen toward the end of this
campaign in honesty we have to accept
that it is being driven the issues being
driven into the dialog by many
progressive folks Howard Dean and the
move on folks and others who believe
it's a serious issue and they have they
have kind of raised it to a higher level
than it certainly was during the
primaries or the conventions I I'm
dubious about a draft I have to be
honest with you I really am dubious
about I'll tell you why I think if you
started drafting people this war in Iraq
would end in about five minutes because
the you know I believe the soldiers over
there
you know I I'd love to see the the
actual ballot count for the soldiers in
Iraq because I think a lot of them would
vote for a ticket home and and so I
think a draft is something that a bush
administration or a Kerry administration
would try very very hard to avoid the
only way we get to a draft in my opinion
is if we have a another very serious
terrorist incident and some sort of
clear you know direction for a response
whether legitimate or not but you know
that's where I would see the possibility
of a draft but I don't see it I just
felt very hard to imagine they're gonna
draft people to maintain the occupation
of Iraq which is already so dramatically
impossible I or unpopular I think that
would tip the balance and I and I think
to them to Bush and Cheney particularly
Cheney maintaining the Iraq initiative
is more important than doing the Iraq
initiative right and so while a draft
might get them a lot of troops and help
to make it a more stable situation I
don't think that's the direction they
would go please
do you think we've seen so many of the
lines blurred will that one to push the
button
the nuclear attack do you think they're
capable of that the lines blurred do you
mean between between preemptive strike
and oh yeah I I think that the the when
we launched a pre-emptive war remember
this country has done pre-emptive wars
in the past it's just that we had the
dignity to lie about it and when we
launched this pre-emptive war without
apology and without the suggestion that
there was legitimate say some legitimacy
to it I think we crossed a very
dangerous line and I think it would be
ridiculous to assume that there is any
aspect of military power or military
intervention military action that isn't
in play I don't think that's the way
that this administration thinks of it at
all I think they think that once you
have the right to launch a preemptive
war you have the right to do it in all
the forms that you might choose to do
and there's nothing in Dick Cheney's
record which is pretty detailed on a lot
of this stuff that would suggest
differently preemptive strike with
incomplete information that was his
statement in the beginning I mean we
should we could do a whole nother a
couple hours on that I know how are we
doing timewise
great please yeah so where myself I'm
interesting to know what happened with
the woman behind this man because very
good question thank you to Lynne Cheney
a fascinating figure I do got a little
chapter on Lynne Cheney I you know
remember it got your names this book
dick is not gonna you know always be mr.
responsible so I did kind of detail her
writings her her wonderful lesbian novel
that she did back in the early 80s
sisters and there are some amazing
tracks from that book let me tell you
she I wouldn't suggest that Lynne change
the greatest writer in the world but
whoo man certainly entertaining in some
ways and but this is a joke about Lynne
Cheney the fact of the matter is she's
super bright she is one of the smartest
people around politics in this country
I've interviewed her professors in fact
I've interviewed some professors who had
her and who actually a new new dick as
well and let's just say the smart
isn't the vice-president Lynne Cheney is
is a super bright super talented woman
could easily have been vice president
herself could easily have done this ride
up herself I mean remember Hillary
Clinton never held an elective office
until 2000 when she was elected to the
US Senate now we all talk about a dream
president well Lynne Cheney very easily
I could have seen a scenario where she
went back to Wyoming got elected to the
Senate and was in place she's that
skillful and that talented and we saw
her talents and skills as a politician
just the other day when the you know he
had in the debate senator Kerry brought
up their daughter the the Cheney's
daughter and mentioned that she was a
lesbian you know I gotta be honest I
think Mitch it's there's no bigger
minefield in politics than mentioning
the family of your opponent and I think
that for Kerry it was a foolish move by
the same token I don't think it was some
sort of big you know in issue it was
like he was out here I mean she was
Coors beers
she was the Coors beer gay and lesbian
outreach director and now she's a member
of the the bush/cheney campaign staff I
mean it's not like this woman isn't one
of the most prominent lesbians in
America but but I think that Kerry may
have made a mistake
but the incredible thing was watch what
Lynne Cheney did she was out there at a
rally within minutes after the debate
finished making this bold statement
about how as a mother I am you know I'm
a I'm an angered mother and how dare he
do this and he's all these you know
tawdry and using others words well the
fact is that was a brilliant political
move and I wasn't dick making that move
it wasn't the bush cheney team maked
this was minutes after it so who had the
the smarts to go in and spin this thing
in a way that actually was quite
effective politically it was Lynne
Cheney she is a very bright figure she
is an absolutely essential figure to
Dick Cheney's success without any doubt
my friend why do you think no one has
mentioned impeachment with this the
impeachment worked well we got a reelect
them first before we can impeach him
right now I mean oh I'm sorry this woman
says real life but here I wrote a book
called Jews for Buchanan about the
Florida disaster and all the all the
elderly garment workers trade unionists
and Holocaust survivors who voted
for pat buchanan for president in that
in that very well-organized florida vote
of two thousand so you're right reelect
is a let's say reefs elect but bottom
line is impeachment won't come into play
as a serious discussion unless these
guys get a second term if it does i
think there will be some dialogue about
it in fact one member of congress
parents would Costello from illinois did
look at some of the Halliburton and
other business dealings and say publicly
that he felt as a member of congress who
dealt a lot in business areas that there
was the grounds for impeachment there
and that it ought to be investigated and
looked into certainly henry waxman and
others have gathered the information and
i will tell you you give me such a good
close off for this event here because
unfortunately oh i do have it
the pin the our little new press which
is a wonderful publishing enterprise led
by andrey schefren and colin robinson
some other great folks a they to promote
the book they did have a pin that says
impeach cheney first and let's be clear
if we're gonna start the impeachment you
do want to get rid of him before you get
rid of bush because of course the making
of president cheney really and you know
let's say right now he's president
enough already thank you so much for
joining us tonight I really enjoy John
Nichols is Washington correspondent for
nation magazine